let's go next to our caller from the 506
area code who's calling today from 506
hello I'm Thomas from Canada hey Thomas
what's going on I'm a little concerned
and I guess there's an open-ended
question but I'm a little concerned with
the stuff I've been reading about yang's
sort of take on climate really and the
climate crisis so there's been like a
number of articles that say Andrew yang
is not your climate friend Andrew yang
report on climate in the debate wasn't
like super well wasn't super well-versed
or whatever okay
and I was just wondering like sort of
your take on that he seemed a little
pessimistic about the issue and not
saying things like we're ten years too
late etc and generally the the issue I
think previously has been like we can't
get politicians on board with climate
change and then yang the sort of issue
that people are talking with yang is
he's on board but he's a little too
pessimistic about it for that is it his
way speaking about it is like super
dystopian I I actually appreciate I mean
okay listen there are candidates who
just deny the science and are completely
disconnected from reality and say oh
everything's fine that's not good there
are candidates who understand the crisis
but seem to think that we're like five
years away from solving everything if
you only elect them which is not
realistic to me so in a sense I find
refreshing his sort of dystopian
pessimistic look a summa doesn't get
over to there's just not even a point in
dealing with this because there's no
fixing it that would be a problem but I
actually appreciate that he's being a
little more frank I mean the the imagery
he used during the second debate on CNN
where he said we've got to start talking
to people about getting to higher ground
because there are coastal areas that are
going to be implying literally
underwater pretty soon I thought that
that was actually really great that he
was using language that communicated the
urgency and sort of crisis that were in
I think the the criticisms might be does
he have
the right plan to deal with it and if
maybe your argument is like you feel
he's so pessimistic that he's not even
focusing enough on climate is that maybe
what I'm hearing well that's that's the
narrative that I sort of saw in the
media yeah but as far as my personal
take on what he said like had I not seen
any other opinions on it if I just watch
like his debate I was like come I was
completely on board with you and him
sort of being like yeah there's an
extent of us that's just sort of screwed
but let's take the action that we can do
in like higher ground et cetera
yeah I mean look I haven't offered the
piece you're talking about I should look
at the piece you're talking about and
see what it argues but in my stew in my
study of Andrew yang and in my
conversations that I've had with him I
think I've had him on three or four
times I've not been alarmed by his his
view on climate I think you know the the
biggest criticism of Andrew Yang's view
on climate and other issues would be he
may see it too much like a consulting
project right the sort of consulting is
a ssin of politics is something that
maybe Andrew yang as someone whose
background is entrepreneurship online
tech startups and whatnot maybe that
would be a fair critique like the the
climate issue is is a cultural issue
it's a scientific issue it's many more
things than just like let's get the
right consultants to solve the problem
that but but even that I'm sort of like
steel Manning the strongest argument
against him ya know like I'm a huge fan
of him and I was just wondering sort of
like how if you had any criticism to the
criticism that he sort of took for that
climate thing and we're on the same page
yeah I mean my reaction yeah he said was
the same as what you said but I should
read the critique you're talking about
and maybe it does have some merit yes
yeah all right Thomas from Canada thank
you where in Canada are you calling from
no oh I've never been there but I've got
to your friends I've got some friends
going up there in this weekend actually
yeah okay great great to hear from you
Thomas hope to hear from you again